if you don't have prior experience
learning foreign languages then starting
a new language can be a really
challenging task and even if you are
motivated things are not easy at the
beginning lots of motivation and little
direction typically leads to a bookshelf
full of
unused language books a phone full of
unopened apps and a learning schedule
that's all over the place and that is if
you spend any time learning at all
instead most of your time is spent
thinking rather
worrying you worry to yourself asking
questions such as which resource should
i start with
when should i start how often should i
sit down to learn how long should each
of my learning sessions be you've
probably found most of these questions
hard to answer especially if you do not
have outside help where usually you
could rely on a teacher or tutor to
provide solutions learning independently
has left you with little to rely on
other than yourself but it doesn't have
to be that way with the right guide and
the right plan you can learn any
language even in the comfort of your own
home far away from any language
classroom hello i'm luka lampariello i'm
a language coach who speaks 14 languages
and on this channel i help people learn
foreign languages more efficiently
faster and in a fun way today i'd like
to share three simple steps that you can
put to use now today to help you begin
learning a new language the smart way
let's dive right in step number one get
the right resources when you're just
starting out in a language the most
obvious thing to worry about is which
learning resources you will use it
doesn't take more than a quick google
search to reveal that for nearly any
language you want to learn there are
hundreds of books apps courses podcasts
flash card decks and more
all intended to help you learn the
language this might seem like a good
thing but the sheer abundance of
available learning materials makes it
impossible to navigate between them and
choose which ones are actually ideal for
your own needs so despite the great
number of resources most people get
stuck at the stage and struggle to move
forward while there are many
characteristics that you could possibly
look for in a good language resource i
recommend that you focus on resources to
have two traits in particular when
choosing a language resource aim for
materials that are comprehensible that
is they feature a language that is
appropriate for your skill level and
interesting that is they feature content
that you find engaging or compelling
resources that meet these two conditions
are most likely to keep you both
challenged and engaged for the longest
period of time which will allow you for
the most learning to take place in my
experience i've found that learning
materials with authentic bilingual texts
in my target language are the ones that
most often meet the comprehensible and
interesting criteria this goes for me
and the hundreds of language learners
i've coached personally why are
bilingual texts so important because
having the text in both your target
language and native language or a
language you know well will help you
compare and contrast the structure of
both languages
and this comparison will help you
gradually gain an understanding of how
each language works in relationship to
the other this type of comparison is
something that you'll do in your head
anyway with or without a bilingual text
but having the text in front of you
makes it smoother and more painless as a
beginner you'll want to look for
bilingual texts that feature short
natural dialogues in your target
language along with audio of those
dialogues even better if the downloads
also come with things like a vocab list
and simple grammar explanations these
extra tools will help you quickly
clarify any words or grammar parts that
are difficult to graph solely from
examining both texts there are a number
of resources on the market today that
have
these features the features i've just
described but i'm personally quite fond
of using asimov's with e's series for
just this purpose asimo is a french
company that provides language course
books in a wide range of language
combinations and these course books are
jam-packed with short funny dialogues
that i found enjoyable across many
different languages if you cannot find
asimo in your language feel free to
check the description box for a link
to my resources page where you can find
many other beginner resources that i
recommend step number two get organized
another important thing to keep in mind
if you want to start learning a language
successfully is to get organized and
stay organized from the very beginning
and for a long time contrary to what you
might think language learning is a
marathon it is not something that you
can just do for a few weeks or a few
months
reach the level you want and then just
forget about it if you do not use your
language skills you lose them so it's of
the utmost importance that before you
start you prepare yourself to learn
every day over a long period of time and
the most important aspects of this
preparation are threefold you must
create a learning space organize a
regular learning schedule and cultivate
a strong mindset for my learning space i
make sure to keep a clean organized and
distraction free area in my room where i
can you know sit down every day and
learn languages i learn in the same spot
every single day so as to train my brain
that this is the spot where learning
happens your learning space can be
anywhere you'd like however i'd
recommend you try to keep it as free of
distractions as possible and that you
learn in the same location every single
day for my learning schedule i try to
keep things consistent and organized as
well specifically i learn at the same
time every day and almost always for the
same amount of time this helps me make
my learning
language learning a habit for added
benefit i do this at the time of day
when i have the most energy so that i
can focus better and more easily for
your learning schedule aim for a daily
time slot of at least 30 to 45 minutes
when you feel most awake and alert try
not to skip it if you do so definitely
do not skip two days as you risk
breaking your learning habit altogether
for my mindset i focus on discipline
over motivation motivation is unreliable
some days you got enough to take on the
world and other days it's nowhere to be
found
when embarking on a challenging
long-term process like language learning
motivation usually ebbs and flows in
unpredictable ways meaning you can
rarely plan on having it when you need
it instead of motivation i rely on
discipline discipline is about showing
up every day whether you feel like it or
not it's about putting in the time and
putting in the effort even if you're not
quite seeing the results you expect just
yet in a word it's about consistency
which if you noticed is a core part of
my learning space my learning schedule
and my mindset if you're feeling low on
discipline you might be wondering how
you can get some too here's a strategy
i've often used that you can try out
yourself if you do not have enough
motivation to start a difficult task
like language learning you can generate
discipline by developing a starting
ritual a starting ritual is a simple
routine that you can practice that
trains your brain to think okay now it's
time to get started your starting ritual
can be anything but i prefer short
simple activities that i can do anywhere
in particular before starting each of my
language learning sessions i like to for
example do one minute of breathing
exercises
do one minute of walking around the room
and sit down at my learning space and
once i've done my breathing and walking
exercises then i know that sitting down
is the signal to get started learning it
sounds simple and it is but these kinds
of starting rituals can be quite
effective at getting started even when
motivation is low if you build a habit
of starting even when you do not feel
like it then you're cultivating
discipline which is going to be an
invaluable tool along your learning
journey step number three reflect on
your progress every day as i said before
learning a language is a process of
long-term growth
though you're learning every day the
steady progress you're making can be
difficult or impossible to see and if
you can't see your progress it can't be
easy to become demotivated and and and
though i said earlier that i do not rely
on motivation i do believe it's
important to watch out for deep
motivation if left unchecked
demotivation often causes people to give
up and stop learning altogether to avoid
the trap of demotivation it's important
to make your
progress visible and to review it
regularly and i do this through keeping
a language learning a notebook now i say
a notebook but what i really mean is a
space to write about your language
learning activities and it doesn't have
to be a physical notebook or a journal
in fact i often use google docs for just
this purpose every day in my language
learning notebook i write down the
language learning activities that i have
done for that day and these are usually
listening reading and translation
activities tied to my bi-directional
translation method which is what i
personally use to start any language
beyond the list of activities i also ask
myself questions which help me reflect
on the quality of my learning for that
day and these include questions such as
do i enjoy my current learning
activities do i find them too easy too
difficult or just challenging enough can
i add or remove anything to make these
activities more effective
is there anything i can do to better
adapt these activities to the language
i'm learning asking myself these
questions keeps me from getting
complacent in my learning activities and
helps me to strive to improve them more
and more over time reflecting in this
way helps me not only keep track of my
developing language skills but also my
developing strategies and techniques for
learning languages as well okay so there
you have it now you've learned the three
simple steps that you can put to use
today to start learning any language if
you're interested in learning more about
how i start learning uh you know new
languages on my own check the link in
the description box and you will find a
link to my brand new online course which
teaches the ins and outs of my very own
bi-directional translation method as
always thanks for watching and happy
language starting
[Music]
[Music]
you